if you've been hoping for some changes
to Battlefield one that I've got some
good news for you EA has announced that
a winner update is coming next week
ahead of the shooters first expansion
I'm Matt this is a game spot news update
and make sure to LIKE and subscribe to
keep up on all of the contents coming to
Battlefield one unfortunately no details
were revealed with the updates
announcement but we do have some idea of
what to expect developer dice recently
launched public test servers for
battlefield one and some of the changes
seen they are include ribbon switch
grand experience for reaching certain
milestones and increase to the maximum
class rank and the ability to vote for
the next map at the end of the match
none of this is confirmed to make it to
the full game but we'll keep you up to
date as more is revealed battlefield
ones first expansion they shall not pass
does not feature Gandalf or any other
wizard instead the french team dlc ads
for maps the french army and a new mode
called front lines among other things
it's coming in March but no specific
release date has been announced we'll
report back when it's revealed but for
some shooter action right now you can
check out our video on the six things we
learned from Ghost Recon wildlands
closed beta
you